all right well how about instead of
buying those cheesy cards no
you make your own kayla cooper from
joanne stores is back to show us how to
create some valentine's day cards hello
thank you for joining us hi thank you
for having me again
so today we're going to be working with
our cricut maker to make some really fun
cutouts
to make some custom cards and i see you
have your cards right there
yes i'll be making one as you uh kind of
guide me and how to do this
so we're going to take our tombow glue
here and it has this really fun tiny
applicator
so you don't get the glue everywhere and
you just apply it to the back of your um
cutouts that you made with your cricut
maker
and one of the things i love about the
qriket maker is that um
i'm doing it on my phone you can use
your smartphone or a tablet
what can you do on your phone the cricut
maker
yes absolutely i don't know if you know
this but the original first gen cricket
you had to have these little pods
and they've upgraded it so now you can
do it on your smartphone with an
app
so it makes it really simple to kind of
create all these really fun
intricate cards oh look how beautiful
that turned out
thank you someone did the cutout
beforehand i'm not going to take credit
for that
i just glue it so what else can we make
with our cricut
so you can make all kinds of fun
projects um today we're just doing
the um cardstock but you can also with
the maker
because it comes with um this adaptive
tool technology
you can cut out vinyl leather
wood metal i i kid you not you can cut
everything with it all in the maker
space on your phone
and it makes it so easy to create custom
projects
and i know plenty of our guests and
customers in the store have even started
their own side businesses
making custom t-shirts and things like
that
and we're all about side businesses i
mean after the year we found everyone's
kind of starting their own etsy shop
this is such a great idea i can't
believe it can cut metal as well kayla
we really appreciate you coming on and
um
i'll have to decide who i'm good ted
maybe one of these is going to you
yeah i don't know it depends how you all
right thank you again kayla and for more
visit joanne.com
las vegas now will be right